Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
If you've ever had a pet, you've probably
wondered what it's thinking or what it gets
up to when you're not there, and that's essentially
the premise of The Secret Life of Pets.
Basically it's Toy Story for our four-legged,
furry, or feathered friends!
There's lots of cool characters which are
interestingly designed and smartly voiced
by a cast of well-known actors including Louis
CK and Modern Family's Eric Stonestreet who
lend their vocal chords to the movie's two
main pooches, Max and Duke.
I loved Lake Bell as fat cat Chloe and Jenny
Slate, who did the voice of Bellwether in
Zootopia, is wonderful as a super-fluffy but
badass Pomeranian called Gidget who adores
telenovelas.
Kevin Hart is also just flat-out fantastic
as the incredibly fluffy and equally insane
bunny Snowball.
And Albert Brooks, who you'll have heard as
Marlin in Finding Nemo and Finding Dory, is
reliably on form as the hungry hawk Tiberius.
Screenwriters Ken Daurio and Cinco Paul, who
did Despicable Me movies, and Brian Lynch,
who did Minions, give us a script that keeps
the pace up throughout, moving forward with
plenty of action and lots of laughs including
visual comedy, animal behaviour-based gags,
and some amusing nods to other movies – speaking
of which, look out for my video on this movie's
easter eggs and references!
There are some superb set-pieces and montages
right from the start, where we're introduced
to the movie's main pets.
There's also a clever scene which shows the
ingenious ways the pets get around the city,
to a crazy funny fantasy sequence.
Directors Chris Renaud and Yarrow Cheney do
a good job keeping us entertained during the
movie's 90-minute run-time, though the film
doesn't quite have the depth, heart, or emotion
of Pixar's best movies, and its story beats
do feel pretty familiar.
Animation-wise, the movie's really bright
and colourful and gives us a rather beautiful
version of New York.
In fact, there's gorgeous shot that flies
through New York City at the start, giving
us all the typical sights: the Statue of Liberty,
Brooklyn Bridge, yellow cabs, the Empire State,
Central Park, and so on, but it's all gorgeously
lit.
Basically, if you enjoyed the Despicable Me
and Minions movies, then odds on you'll enjoy
this too, Can definitely see them making more
of these movies.
Oh, and right before The Secret Life of Pets,
we get a short film called Mower Minions featuring
everyone's favourite banana-loving mischief-makers
who prove to be as much fun as ever.
It's nice to see them again ahead of next
summer's Despicable Me 3.
So, to sum up: The Secret Life of Pets is
a colourfully animated, vibrant and energetically-paced
feature which pulls back the curtain on what
our pets get up to when left alone.
In terms of story and emotion, it doesn't
quite reach the level of the thematically
similar Toy Story or the recent fellow animal
feature Zootopia, however, it is a charming
flick with some fab characters and voice cast
and a bundle of laughs.
And we get an added Minions short, so what's
not to like?!
The Secret Life of Pets gets 3 and a half
out of 5 Flicks.
Now, what did you think of The Secret Life
Of Pets and the Minions short?
And what would you like to see in Despicable
Me 3?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this review, I'd love it if you'd
share it, and do subscribe for more movie
reviews, Easter Egg videos and amazing movie
facts!
Click the links here to check those out!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!